bonsoir jean françois bach merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
après cette énième conseil de défense
sanitaire le flou persiste on a du mal à
y voir plus clair les français sont
perdus emmanuel macron demande des
analyses supplémentaires sur la
prévalence du variant anglais avant de
prendre des décisions cette souche b 1-1
certains comme elle se nomme réellement
c'est quoi c'est une épidémie dans
l'épidémie comment est-ce que elle
circule sur le territoire français non
je ne dirais pas une épidémie dans
l'épidémie parce que c'est assez courant
dans des épidémies virales qu'il y ait
des mutants qui évolue donc c'est une
dérive un peu d'épidémie c'est la
première importante et pas forcément la
dernière
non ce qui fait pas fait que ça change
le rythme de l'épidémie et ce qui est
bien sûr difficile gérer c'est qu'on ne
sait pas absolument à quel rythme si ça
s'accélère vite les comprends pas des
mesures assez rapidement on rit de
déborder si inversement c'est pas aussi
grave qu'on pense au risque d'en faire
trop ou alors c'est tellement sensible
beaucoup denis bourque que vous avez
évoquées il faut évidemment car savent
beaucoup dé faire demain 10 à 15 % quand
même 20% angeli annan tout à l'heure
qu'on avait en invitant le chef
réanimation de l'hôpital de garches part
de 20% des tests positifs aux copies de
19 qui seraient des variants issus du
mario anglais
vous dites on ne sait pas quand cette
souche remplacera la souche initial on a
un ordre d'idée quand même et lorsque ce
sera effectif quelles seront les
conséquences
alors et on parle on ne peut parler que
de ce qu'on connaît qui est maintenant
établie c'est que le taux de présence de
ce barrière va augmenter il va
d'ailleurs pas forcément augmenter de la
même façon dans toutes les régions et de
complication supplémentaire mais enfin
il va augmenter des modélisations
indique yves atteint 30 40 % c'est alors
c'est pas forcément beaucoup plus grave
ça veut lancer ce qui est ennuyeux c'est
que ça va augmenter le nombre de cas
chaque cas individuel ne soit pas
fondamentalement différent des cas
précédents cas chauffe et cela a été
suggéré par le premier ministre anglais
mais se doit d'être établi donc sauf
événement extraordinaire la maladie
reste la même c'est simplement parler de
du premier ministre britannique boris
johnson il a dit que ce variant ou
pouvait être potentiellement plus
mortelle mais votre avis dit monologue
est ce qu'on se retrouve face à un
nouveau virus qu'on ne connaît pas
pardonnez moi l'expression mais ce qu'on
va encore devoir remballer la population
d'une annonce à une autre avant de
démentir ces annonces ici ou là
alors le problème j'avais fait que dans
tout cela il ya la science que la
politique je m'occupe de l'achat
je vois bien les l'embarras des
politiques que j'aimerais pas être à
leur place c'est très compliqué et les
problèmes en angleterre ne sont pas au
royaume uni en général soient pas les
mêmes qu'en france tout ce qu'on voyait
mini ils ont un nombre considérable qui
sont pas morts devant un problème plus
difficile que l'autre jour mais donc moi
je partirai des principes qu'aujourd'hui
dans l'état actuel des connaissances il
n'est pas démontré que ce variant donne
des formes plus sévères que le virus que
nous avons actuellement cela dit il
il se dit plus contagieux donc le nombre
de cas la courbe d'augmentation risque
d'être plus rapide qu'elle a été dans
les vagues précédentes c'est ça ne c'est
ça le problème
vous dites il n'est pas démontré je me
permets de revenir sur sur les vaccins
coûte des vaccins puisque les sorties
médiatiques des scientifiques notamment
10 10 les études qu'on a ne montre pas
que les vaccins ne sont pas efficaces
mais les scientifiques ne disent pas
mais vous ne dites pas aller les études
montrent que les vaccins sont efficaces
la négation elle est importante dans les
déclarations parce qu'au final savons
qu'on sait pas grand chose
non ce qui était montré ce que l'on sait
aujourd'hui c'est que il ya deux choses
différentes à la gravité de la maladie
par elle-même à des pantalons
bon là je vous dit il n'y a pas de
raison de penser aujourd'hui qu'elle
sera qui va même s'il ya plus de cas la
deuxième question f que les vaccins qui
sont utilisés aujourd'hui vont protéger
et les sujets vaccinés vacciner contre
ce variant britannique et la réponse on
a des éléments de réponse important la
réponse est oui
ce qui n'est pas absolument le cas au
même niveau pour les autres variant sud
africain ou brésiliens les poules
variant angles et maintenant on peut
dire que effectivement les vaccins vont
protéger c'est quand même très rassurant
oui c'est rassurant mais vous parlez d
autres varaillon vous avez parlé de
variants sud africains brésiliens dont
il a évoqué le variant angles est
évidemment il ya les arrivants
californien maintenant elle s'en sort
plus à cornebarrieu en breton corse et
savoyards quoi oui oui novem les raisons
c'est une complication de cette épidémie
pour les autres ce que l'on sait
actuellement et qu' il y a peut-être
sans doute on n'a pas les chiffres
c'était tout récent tout ça ça fait
quelques quelques jours il semble que
pour le varésan sud africain de la
protection apportée dans les vaccins et
arn messager et témoin bonne elle existe
toujours mais les moins bonnes et titre
des anticorps sont moins bons alors à
partir de ça est ce que ça va diminuer
la protection apportée par les packs
chat nous avons actuellement contre ces
variants sud africains brésiliens
on ne sait pas encore vraiment mais
c'est une possibilité alors que ce n'est
pas une possibilité pour le variant
britannique assurait être à se re sur ce
point et puis un autre élément quand
même qu'il faut pointer un peu des
inscrits c'est que la technologie des
vaccins et l
que si c'était nécessaire si vraiment
les personnes n'avaient pas toute leur
efficacité contre les variants aux sud
africains et brésiliens ou d'autres qui
pourraient exister
il est assez facile de refaire un vaccin
par derrière dans quelques mois
donc ça c'est une bonne nouvelle mais
après se posera évidemment la question
de la logistique de la production et ce
sont d'autres considérations évidemment
merci beaucoup jean françois bach
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes immunologue
secrétaire perpétuel de l'académie des
sciences